bonsoir nadège vous suivez cette
cérémonie d'hommage aux victimes
les fidèles qui sont l'imaginent
nombreux en ce confinement à se rendre
en l'église notre dame de l'assomption
alors magali à cette messe de la
toussaint faut savoir qu elle est
célébrée par andré marsault l évêque de
nice cette messe qui fait aussi office
de cérémonie d'hommage aux aux trois
victimes de l'attentât de jeudi un qui a
eu lieu à l'intérieur de cette basilique
notre dame de l'assomption cérémonie
solennelle plein d'émotion à laquelle
participe seulement 150 personnes triées
sur le volet restrictions dues à la
crise sanitaire oblige à l'air ont été
invités les membres
les proches des victimes à des fidèles
paroissiens et puis quelques
personnalités politiques locales comme
par exemple christian estrosi le maire
de nice ou encore eric ciotti le député
les républicains des alpes maritimes
alors plusieurs dizaines de niçois ont
aussi fait le déplacement un pur et bien
rendre un ultime hommage même s'ils
n'ont pas pu entrer à l'intérieur de la
basilique ils ont tenu à être présent
pour cette cérémonie d'hommage je vous
propose d'en écouter quelques uns se
recueillir avec tous les français pour
rendre un hommage aux victimes et être
de tout coeur avec les familles qui ont
été atterrés par cette part cet épisode
dramatique
voilà
et se joindre avec la l'ensemble des
catholiques et de d'être présent de
coeur avec avec tout le monde
j'avais pas très loin je suis dans
j'habite cette vie depuis 20 ans et ce
qui s'est passé vraiment très choquant
ça ne touche au quotidien et il est
important d'être là même si on n'a pas à
avoir peur mais c'est important d'être
là
pour la solidarité la citoyenneté
revenais je venais souvent dans cette
cathédrale chaque fois que je vais
passer je venais me recueillir et voilà
c'est pas une question de peur c'est une
question de de retrouver notre savoir
vivre et puis c'est honorer ces gens là
qui sont morts malheureusement à cause
de d'imbécillité cause d'ignorance et
voilà je voulais être présente pour
honorer parce que bon c'est vrai je suis
croyante mais surtout pour notre liberté
à des niçois qui ont aussi apporté des
fleurs allumer des bougies en je le
disais pour rendre hommage aux victimes
alors que la messe de la toussaint se
déroule toujours actuellement au moment
où je vous parle à l'intérieur de cette
basilique notre-dame de l'ascension des
prières particulières ont été adressées
aux trois victimes de l'attentât
l'émotion est donc au rendez-vous encore
aujourd'hui un pour ce jour si
particulier pour la communauté et
chrétienne et trois jours après avoir
été la cible du terrorisme
merci beaucoup nadège pour toutes ces
précisions la neige abderrezak en direct
de nice